en este vídeo voy a crear un canal de
YouTube únicamente utilizando la
Inteligencia artificial el objetivo de
este vídeo es ver cuántas visitas
consigo generar en tan solo 7 días para
este canal de YouTube lo que he decidido
ha sido subir cinco vídeos al día para
preparar estos 35 shorts lo que hice fue
pedirle al chat cpt que me deje este 35
cosas curiosas sobre el dinero entonces
lo primero que hice para ponerme editar
puedes cargar una serie de vídeos de un
Gameplay de coches Así que es lo mismo
que hice yo entonces una vez que tuve el
fondo lo que hice fue utilizar Microsoft
Edge es la aplicación que se ha ocupado
de pasar de texto a audio todo el guión
de todos los vídeos Bueno chicos ya ha
pasado Ni más ni menos que unas semanas
siete días desde que creé el canal
Únicamente con Inteligencia artificial y
en total si venimos a estadísticas nos
aparece que hemos conseguido 21.300
visitas y 114 horas de reproducción y 47
suscriptores pero lo que quiero calcular
ahora es cuánto dinero hubiésemos
generado gracias a este canal para hacer
esto voy a utilizar estas estadísticas
que son las estadísticas de mi propio
canal de YouTube y esto es el rpm que
básicamente Esto es lo que te paga
YouTube por cada 1000 visitas que
estamos hablando de que paga 3 céntimos
por cada mil visitas Así que teniendo en
cuenta las visitas que he conseguido con
el canal de YouTube he generado Ni más
ni menos que 63 céntimos